like the paxman interview i saw was a
very similar one it's a political one
yeah but it was very and he didn't play
up the goofy as much was again somebody
trying to get him and talk them in
circles and then you talk them in
circles do you lean into
kind of being aloof because you know i
can win that way and the win is that
much more satisfying actually i wish i
could say that because that sounds
really cool but like he's much more this
i i'm i'm involved in a negotiation with
fear quite a lot of the time like so i'm
not like i don't walk into environments
i think yeah [ __ ] all you like i'm a bit
like oh [ __ ] you know i mean so i'm
dealing with the reality of that i'm
dealing with the reality of fear
like not in a hopefully a high-pitched
anxious way but i'm observing the fear
which i've come through training and
time to regard as your body is
energizing now in case you have to be
fast you know dealing with what
adrenaline is rather than uh
pathologizing
adrenaline into a neurotic state but i
don't feel like i'm going to go in there
and i'm going to [ __ ] him up although in
my mind i do think when i'm dealing with
something like jeremy paxman who's like
i don't know he's like maybe he's like
anderson cooper or something like that
yeah he's like a political commentator
and he again was like trying to get you
trying to get me yeah right and also
that stuff the other thing is we should
like is i believe in that stuff i
believe that like that primarily
political discourse is carried out in a
way to exclude ordinary people and even
the distractional tactics of turning
people against one another on the basis
of race or gender ignores the crucial
arguments around class that most
ordinary people have more in common with
one another than they have in common
with the elites that govern them and
that's always kept off the table while
the they exacerbate our differences to
turn us against one another so when i'm
like actually confronting one of those
people i think [ __ ] no i'm talking to
him right now like so when i'm like i
tried to stay very very calm and then if
they personally [ __ ] do me it's like
yeah that's it now i'm ready let's go
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause that's rude
i'm an
englishman gauntlet around the chops
isn't it yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's so what it is is i
don't go in there sort of overly
confident but i do go in there with a
sort of a set of beliefs that i sort of
hold on to so something like that
morning i weren't in a very good mood
actually that and that the morning
yeah that one where it's that lady with
the blonde hair my cup yeah you know
like when like when i went on that i
didn't feel that good and now i weren't
particularly happy with the trousers i
was wearing to be honest
and like so like when on top of that
they would start mugging me off i
thought oh no yeah they thought that
they were trying to have like uh i think
they thought they were gonna have fun
with you like they thought that you were
gonna come in they were gonna tease you
yeah you were gonna be the clown and
they were just gonna kind of laugh at
you and you didn't look that happy going
into it which is always funny when
you're trying to convince people to come
to your happy show
yeah i'm terrible at that and and buddy
there was a moment where you just said
decided you're like okay well this
interview is about to get taken over
right now and i'm going to tell these
people who i am and it's going to be
really interesting and they [ __ ] fold
it
yeah they've got nothing to look at them
people no disrespect to them they're
probably all like beautiful human beings
secretary or something
well that doesn't seem right was the
secretary particularly inefficient
was there a tribunal process
was there an opportunity to discuss the
kpis
they're not delivering in these
straight to execution yeah no more
justice on an individual level